in this case study we go back to the
question we continue asking what do you
want me to see so sometimes when I'm
asked to help out with an image I have
no idea what's in store for me for
example the first time I walked through
this particular lab I had no clue what
to look for the researchers suggested
starting with this setup showing part of
their system which developed a more
efficient way of capturing and storing
energy for me that setup just didn't
convey the excitement of the science but
then as I turn towards the chamber I saw
where the solar thermo photovoltaic
device or St PV device was doing its
thing the chamber was covered with
aluminum foil as many chambers are in
laughs I've noticed but I was able to
focus my eye on the window of the
chamber it looked really beautiful to me
my initial image was a mess at first a
little too much going on so I decided to
simplify the idea as we continued
talking about I deleted all that foil
and just concentrated on the circular
window showing the device I then
digitally added a background for
potential submission when I returned to
the lab a few days later with a
different device in the chamber I
decided to add some color by reflecting
an orange cloth I saw hiding in the
corner somewhere in front of the glass
and this time focusing in on just the
device in the chamber I moved the camera
closer shooting at around f/32 notice
how the depth of field is narrow since I
am quite close to the window I imagined
what I was going to do with the cropped
focus
section first I overlaid it on an image
of the vacuum chamber from before as I
shot the floor then I decided to try
something else using the single image of
the device again I digitally stretched
part of
image to make it more vertical and then
overlay the original image on the
vertical image so that the device became
proportionally right happily got the MIT
homepage highlight so that was nice